so Joe you have your own media company
yes Joe Haas John's media.com okay gonna
it's on the way and how did you learn
about cameras did you go to film school
I did not go to film squad did go to
school for broadcasting you know so I
had some exposure to it there and in
terms of you know electronic news
gathering things like that and using a
camera and such but I didn't really
start getting into you know more thought
into it you know until I start shooting
photos and then I started concentrating
a composition a lot more movement etc in
the photos and then when you have a
moving medium like video to work with
it's just like whoa this is cool i can
use all these same principles and a
whole lot of trial and error along the
way and plane with buttons never since i
met joe like my first charles 19 coming
up from college and Joe I mean Joe has
had a camera on him at all times so it's
been interesting like I can mention for
to see him progress um it's yeah I'm
honest it's cool it's cool to see his
work so what are some quick tips that
you can tell someone about using a DSLR
because it seems like it's so easy or
you use them but I know there's it's not
as easy as it looks and it's a lot of
trial here yeah i mean the you
stabilization of some sort you know
whether that be a shoulder moderate
tripod that's key and get to know the
relationship between your your you know
your f-stop and your shutter speed and
and what that does to your depth of
field and what that does to the way it
just the way it looks you know so figure
all that stuff out don't use anything
automatic um yeah I never know what
you're going to get with that that's for
sure and that's with dslrs I realize the
shoulder mounts for the DSLRs they're
great because you can do photos and
videos right I do think that 4k
resolution will be
bury it already is pretty accessible and
I think pretty soon you're going to be
able to get a full blown 4k camera with
for a couple thousand dollars probably
so fully school and then invest money in
lenses you know really really get some
glass you know to get down to 2.8 if
you're intending that effect is really
nice to have that flexibility especially
in situations where you don't have a lot
of light and you can't check the ISO up
you know do you have any tips for making
it not look so grainy at night just just
that lens is hmm yeah not grainy at
night I mean get more light I number
wonderful make sure iso is now another
matter ed so your media company when did
that happen and was that always
something you were going to do once you
left college well I just kind of like
doing it you know I just believe you
kind of got to do what you like to do
and so you know and plus all the
learning that was going on with it and
plus technology and computers and
software it was all very fun to pick up
so it kind of just progressed naturally
I don't know if it was really conscious
decision at all but um I just like doing
it work was improving and I was paying
the bills with it so this kind of
actually goes on as long as you invest
back into what you're doing so whatever
you would make you then buy more fitness
yeah you know just a little better this
a little better that one of these some
more of those you know that kind of
stuff you know
you